hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen map
vorstellung ich habe schon länger keine
vorstellung mehr gemacht ganz einfach
weil die kompletten mit vorstellungen
naja ich weiß nicht da sind nicht so
viele leider merkt raus gekommen wo ich
mir dachte hey dazu kann ich jetzt im
vorstand machen
von daher habe ich mir jetzt einfach
eine etwas ältere wep ausgesuchte zwar
ist eine subway surfer snap wir können
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle subway
servers von damals von oder ich weiß
nicht spielt ist man auch auf my phone
könnte oder android oder ipod könne man
die kommentare schreiben kennt jetzt
besser etwas bzw spielte das noch eher
weil das ist eine map wohl genau das tun
könnte ich gehe mal ganz kurz aus so
bleibt wir sind hier in einer dings wir
haben ein bisschen geschwindigkeits
verstärkung und ich würde sagen wir
fangen direkt an wenn es nicht einfach
auf den tunnel zu laufen soll jetzt
geht's los und jetzt haben wir zwei
minuten zeit und müssen diese parcours
bewältigen das ist einfach nur eine map
aufgebaut wie bei subway servers halt
ein paar waggons in der mitte und wenn
man über so teilen her will muss man
auch seinen knopf drücken dann wird man
danach teleportiert und manchmal muss
man auch einfach darüber dass es dann so
ungefähr das sind dann solche zeichen
drin
man hat am anfang jetzt habe ich gerade
zwei minuten zeit um diesen parcours
hier zu bewältigen und ihr seht unten
meine experience die gehen runter
das sind die das ist die zeit die ich
bisher noch habe um diesen parcours zu
bewältigen so das ist jetzt natürlich
nicht mehr ganz so viel zeit deswegen
hoffe ich mal dass ich das schaffe
meinen pc hat nun ein bisschen weil ich
noch nebenbei am rechner mit photoshop
offen habe
das schafft auch mein neuer pc nicht so
versuche ich hier nochmal zu springer
habe 72 sekunden das ganze noch zu
beenden
gleich ist die hälfte der zeit schon rum
und das auch schon das ziel und ich kann
jetzt einfach in das tier einlaufen sagt
dann steht da unten welche im chat das
hingekriegt habe blabla time to complete
habe ich jetzt noch 1 minute 50 also ich
hatte jetzt 110 sekunden
weil ich dort auch auf beginner stufe
bin kein sie einfach mal weiterlaufen
muss jetzt den schalter drücken welcher
nach silber täter muss wieder hoch
springen also es ist halt wirklich so
wie subway servers könnt ihr einfach mal
spielen und es hat auch man braucht
keine mods und das irgendwie zu spielen
und es hat eine integrierte score system
das heißt am ende ist eine anzeigetafel
da könnt ihr sehen wie viel der ihr
wurdet und sohn wie lange gebraucht hat
und alles also ist eigentlich ganz cool
gemacht findet
ich musste auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen schneller sein 74 sekunden habe
ich noch ist auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen zeit zu mir ich mache das
manchmal so lange wie ich das ungefähr
ist es insgesamt 3000 meter strecke also
3000 blöcke in der länge die hier
verbaut wurden ich bin bisher insgesamt
noch nicht nur ein kilometer denke ich
gelaufen
so jetzt sind wir hier so was echt grad
kassam ruckeln das tut mir echt leid
aber muss man nun hat man jetzt mit
leben das ich in den ball noch ränder
und die ganzen kerne ausgelastet sind
ich möchte euch natürlich regelmäßig
videos geben bringen deswegen so ziehen
mal rum und jetzt hier wieder durch
hierüber habe es noch 60 sekunden also
ihr seht schon die zeit wenn immer
weniger und nachher wird dann natürlich
angezeigt im highscore wie lange ihr am
besten wahrt und so was alles ich habe
selbst noch einmal bis zum hsv gespielt
ich habe bisher immer nur gespielt und
nur dann habe ich das tutorial
gespielten danach habe ich gedacht da
kommen sie direkt darunter auch hier das
erste mal lässt sich gar nicht große die
net zeigen weil die verändert sich ja
nicht im gegensatz zu subway service
offen handy so davis auch wieder
geschafft jetzt geht es weiter
okay hier noch mal lang und hier und
hier hört auch so ein time glocken jetzt
im hintergrund ich habe jetzt auch noch
70 sekunden ihr könnt euch erinnern
vorhin hatte ich ganz am anfang noch so
120 und am ende hingegen 70 aber naja
was ich euch eigentlich auch noch zeigen
wollte sind items die nachhallzeit
einfach kommen und zwar kann es sein
dass ihr einfach mal aufs am waggon
sondern sondern mode blog findet sowie
daten nicht so laut blog sondern so
einfach eine 1
ein schild schäfers hochgeht und das
steht dafür dass ihr über einen item
laufteams gibt es dann zum beispiel dass
man mal +10 sekunden kriegt allerdings
tauschen kaufen die ihr später auf
beziehen also man muss sie sich nachher
im shop kaufen gibt es natürlich auch
alles ich möchte das hier allerdings
euch nun mal ganz kurz zeigen den rest
könnt ihr einfach selber rausfinden
indem ihr recht einfach downloaded der
downloadlink ist und in der beschreibung
nach 28 sekunden ist das ende schaffte
er sogar nicht schreibt in die
kommentare
ja okay ich werde wahrscheinlich
schaffen so hey so treffer direkt links
so weitergeht sieht noch jetzt habe ich
nur noch 1 68 sekunden musste schaffen
und es wird immer heftiger also hier
sind immer mehr schranken die mir
wirklich den weg versperren
und ich muss mich echt schon dran halten
dass ich jetzt nicht wie bei sterbe ihr
seht schon hier jetzt jemand ein
bisschen verändert worden
beziehungsweise die map ist allgemein
immer anders also natürlich wenn die
neue startet kommt ihr natürlich in der
gleichen marke erst mal raus hier haben
wir zum beispiel einen städtchen 2/10
sekunden endet sind das war vielleicht
auch noch runter ob gott ich spiele
gratis [ __ ] mit 25 ps wobei das eher
normal sonst habe ich zum beispiel macht
hänge ich da erst mal paar sekunden
chefs schild darum habe ich zum beispiel
gerade zehn sekunden fach so drauf
gekriegt habt ihr gesehen stand ja auch
auf dem schild drauf so das heißt ich
habe jetzt ja zehn sekunden drauf
gekriegt
nein also ich bin gar nicht konzentriert
das gleich muss das schaffen ich habe
noch 26 sekunden ein ende ist nicht in
sicht
doch dahin ist das ende
euro leute ich schwimme okay ich hab's
geschafft so ich habe jetzt noch 12
sekunden übrig wahrscheinlich dass jetzt
auch noch schaffe wir können einfach mal
schauen wie weit ich da insgesamt komme
wo es ruckelt es ruckelt es ruckelt es
ruckelt wie sonst was ich habe es noch
53 sekunden leute ihr seht die zeit geht
runter wie wie geschnittene bruder du
was ist eingeschnittene butter luca
fragt ihr euch jetzt hat frage ich mich
auch immer am frühstückstisch setze ich
denk mir so was ist eigentlich
geschnittene butter das ist eine frage
die wird auch der einstein er die damals
noch nie beantworten können weil das ist
einfach eine frage da muss man ganz tief
in die materie reingehen geschnittene
bruder das ist genauso wie was war
zuerst da das huhn oder das ei
oder ich krank es sei natürlich eine
frage kann den kopfball war denkt ihr
denn war zuerst das huhn da oder war
zuerst es eine weil das huhn kann ja
nahe legen einfach so ohne irgendwie
geschäftliche aktivitäten und
das kabinett und dabei wenn er schlüpft
dann ist es ja auch ein huhn und das
kann dann auch wieder legen also was ist
was war zuerst da kann ja unabhängig
voneinander einfach fortpflanzen das ist
ja das ist jetzt echt ranzig dass er
richtig ranzig das ist jetzt echt
braucht gott schirm da hätten wir
vielleicht auch zwei sekunden gefehlt
gut ist es vorbei jetzt bin ich wieder
hier drin jetzt muss ich einfach dahin
laufen damit dieser wieder wenn man
sieht jetzt hier muss man derzeit aus
oder sind die zeiten wie lange man für
was brauche ich hatte am ende nur noch
difficult da 550 650 regen wieso und bis
dahin werde ich das dann geschafft hätte
ich es quasi durchgespielt geht auf dem
iphone bzw android nicht ja freunde das
war's das war's nein also das war
subway servers in minecraft und ich
hoffe euch ausgefallen wenn es euch
gefallen hat schreibt doch einfach in
die kommentare
subway servers man sich das immer noch
dabei sein und gibt auch einfach einen
daumen hoch weil dann soll ich eventuell
mehr vorstellungen machen könnt ihr auch
einen kommentar schreiben aldi kommt
aber schreiben ja wieder ordentlich was
zu schreiben jetzt ist natürlich auch
finger sportler wenn ihr die finger
betätigt selbst kann später sein dass
ihre gelenke griff gehabt und ihr nicht
so eine starre bekommt wenn ihr
regelmäßig auf der tastatur um tippt das
ist wirklich so das haben ihnen welche
wissenschaftler wiesen oder irgend sowas
keine ahnung hab ich gelesen wird auf
jeden fall sagen wir sehen zunächst mal
tschüss